hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar titled host and viral
transcriptomes
during covid19 infection this webinar is
part of the coronavirus virtual event
series
and i'm susie valdez of labyrinths and i
will be your moderator for today's event
today's educational seminar is presented
by
lab roots so let's get started before we
begin i want to remind everyone that
this event is interactive and we
encourage you to participate
by submitting as many questions as you
want during the presentation
to do so simply type them in ask a
question box
and click send we'll answer as many
questions as we can at the end of the
presentation
if you have any trouble seeing or
hearing this presentation
click on the ask a question box located
on the top
left of your screen as a reminder this
presentation
is educational and offers free
continuing education credits
click on the continuing education
credits tab located on the top right
corner
of your presentation window and follow
the process to obtain those credits
i now present today's speaker dr chris
mason
associate professor of genomics
physiology and biophysics
at well cornell medicine and the
director of
world quant initiative for quantitative
prediction
for a complete biography on our speakers
please visit the biography tab at the
top
of your screen dr mason welcome you may
now begin
your presentation sir
oh all right great um just giving it a
couple seconds i know the transition on
the recording
and okay well great uh good morning
afternoon or evening to everyone who's
uh tuning in
it's a pleasure to be here and thanks
for the invitation to come and speak and
talk about some of our work which is um
excuse me well i'll start over it's a
pleasure to be here thanks for having me
come speak
it's a pleasure to kind of go over some
of our recent work on covid and related
uh host characterization of what the
virus does when it enters the body
and in particular i'm going to walk
through a lot of uh different code as
well as a result from looking at the
covet patients that
was some of the first ones to walk
through the door in the beginning of the
pandemic in march in new york city
and what we've learned since then and
how we're applying this to new areas of
startup and rapid testing and different
communities and i will um
of course uh the these slides will be
available also often we'll tweet these
slides out so you can uh get them from
twitter
which is a good place for sharing
scientific data as well as a major
platform for
presidential policy announcements so uh
i want to describe a little bit about
what we were thinking as the
virus started ravaging through new york
city and ways to better understand
what we were up against and also to
understand what was doing to the body
and i kind of made this slide in the
early part of the pandemic to think well
there's a lot of ways you can look at
rna once you get a swab you want to get
either dna and or rna out and start to
characterize it and then you know we
realized
uh that you can do some things that
people are very familiar with like rtpcr
of course these are things that
people are very familiar with are like
our rna-seq but we're going to think
about more deeper rna sequencing for
host
and viral profiling then also sort of
look at capture methods and also
lamp which i'll talk about a bit at the
end or loop-mediated isothermal
amplification
so um as we got the first 735 samples we
did some of them in duplicate but we got
857
coven 19 suspected patients sequenced to
about 63 million reads for each one
and in particular this included 216 that
were confirmed by positive buyer tpcr
519 negative and then also some
environmental samples and then other
uh wide range of controls such as very
sick cells then some synthetic rnas and
controls
or just for buffer so almost everything
i'll present in the first half of the
talk or so
is uh on our pre-printathon line and
also there's an interactive website
which i'll show you where
if people are looking for expression
dynamics as a function of the virus
present
we put that up there as well so
what you can see is you know when the
first one we did rna-seq and lamp and
rxt pcr and all the samples
each vertical line here is a sample and
we did first thing was a from the
shotgun
meta transcriptomic data mapped all the
reads to different kingdoms and domains
of life and see where they map and you
can see here
in blue the human reads were heavily
abundant some of the
nasopharyngeal swabs np swabs in some
cases we get a lot of bacterial rna
but then in other cases those that were
rt pcr positive of course we would see
large amounts of the star cov2 virus and
there were occasionally some potentially
false negatives
with the rt pcr but they were very rare
and contrary to what was predicted in
the early parts of the
outbreak where some people thought maybe
30 of false negatives might be occurring
by rt pcr we don't think that's the case
but we could see in some cases you know
is it there but even really easy to see
where almost 80
of the rna from a sample would be viral
rna
and so the next thing i want to think is
well you know there's this distribution
of the reeds as they map to
different uh you know domains of life
but what else could we do with the human
rna data
in particular could we use it to do a
cellular deconvolution
matrix using music or we've used a
variety of other tools
uh like you use excel or sort that they
all have
they generally work well well but we use
music here uh to
basically take the signatures of known
cell types and then
break down what was uh what was actually
in the np swab when we sequenced it so
in particular
this let's predict based on airway
essentially these are known
airway annotations for different cell
types and these are nasal you can see
here at the bottom i can see the screen
and most of them were ciliated or goblet
cells you can see and there's some
dendritic evidence of dendritic cells
compared to the nasal
profile but for the most part it was
ciliated in goblet cells that we could
detect
and then we also did this as a function
of let's say viral abundance or
of location and did this by some e-mail
plots to see
if your rt pc are positive or negative
does that change whether you're a
ciliated or goblet cell
did there seem to be any enrichment of
any type of cell that was being infected
and for the most part we could see they
didn't see there's no statistically
significant enrichment
uh in these different categories you can
sometimes see high and low in each one
of them for example
and so this gave us an ability to say
high lower medium amounts of viral
infection
and also essentially you can see the
total number of reads on the right here
so what we want to do then is say okay
we know what's being infected what if we
get enough of the virus sequence can we
then actually call genetic variants and
use that to infer
features of the virus different present
so for example
could we use this to trace the
evolutionary history of the virus now
indeed we could actually so this regard
we really take
the known variance compared to the wuhan
strain you can see here from 0 to 30 kb
is the genome the reference for star cv2
and we could actually using as a lot of
the next strain algorithms get 155
fully covered and assemble genomes so
you can then see where they map onto the
gis data the global
database of what was originally designed
for influenza but now has all the
coronavirus that have been sequenced
around the world
deposited online and so we can see there
are some consistent uh
differences you can see these
substitutions showing up often really
consistent relative to the wuhan strain
other ones we could see deletions or
insertions uh what's interesting is you
can see not only
these small variants but some of the big
ones we could see for example uh this
was a
essentially an nine base pair three
amino acid deletion
that was in a this you can see in black
as the sequence similar between star cv2
and the coronavirus those from 2003 star
cov and in this area that's
generally pretty conserved we could see
this deletion of the c terminal region
of nsp1
which had already been linked to host
chemokine dysregulation
and immune response this is actually you
know a fairly uh
important you know deletion that we
could see in our samples and this you
know kind of beg the question
well okay we see it here you know can we
see it in other samples and indeed we
aren't the only ones so
one of the most extraordinary things
about this you know time really living
in research and
responding to a pandemic is you know
while it's terrifying to think about the
scale of what's happened because the
outbreak it's also amazing that
in a matter of you know really weeks we
had a genome reference in a matter of a
couple months we had
global sharing of different uh you know
genome very complete genome so we can
see
how we see this deletion but now where
is it it's in australia we can see it's
in england
it's in reykjavik we could pick out all
these different areas around the world
where it could be detected and so the
thing we wanted to
look for is see well do we see any
differences in new york versus others
does this
maybe partly explain why new york got
hit so hard and indeed we could see some
evidence of enrichment for different
alleles you can see the new york city
clade here
from the cornell samples or new york
presbyterian compared to those found in
say
nyu or mount sinai other places in new
york and relative to outside of new york
we did see some statistically
significant enrichments
and this gave us an ability to see and
define really a new york city clade
that was really enriched within you know
new york mount sinai uh
and you know generally the new york city
clayton you can see them here
uh new york city in general is in red
and also uh
you know ours are in red in new york
city broadly outside of
cornell and new york presbyterian is
here in green so
uh consistent recapitulation is
phenotype but this gave us a way to
define the clade which was 20c
uh that seemed to be enriched and we
thought well uh you know
what does this look like elsewhere in
the world and so again another really
great feature of the next drain database
and gas 8 is we can say well
given we saw a lot of enrichment of this
clay 20c in new york city it was
early in the pandemic if you look in the
upper right and really stayed that way
but was
the other clades were not as enriched in
new york city if you look at the east
coast midwest or west coast and these
sort of
these other three areas here these rows
you can see as a function of time
uh east coast of course increased driven
a lot by new york but midwest increased
over time the
west coast not as much but you don't see
this clade really that much at all if
you look over to asia or europe
uh or in some cases oceana although it's
a little bit noisy there's very few
samples
so this gives you a really interesting
way to track sort of the clades and
movement of the virus
around the world and because of this
geospatial differentiate
differential this is something i'll
bring up later that you can take a
virus really from anywhere if you
sequence it from sewage from a hospital
from a random you know shoe on the
street
uh if you get the variance you can get a
likelihood estimate of where it came
from in the world
based on these you know geospatial
distinctions
so that's just thinking about
coronavirus but since it's a shotgun rna
sequencing that also gives us the
capacity
to look at other viruses that are
present so in particular you know it
will work like what the seattle flu
studies been doing for years of trevor
bedford and others
jason durie is to say okay we know we
expect other viruses to appear this is
what we're seeing when we get into march
like para influenza other strains of
influenza rhinoviruses
and so we're able to do this again for
this paper and we could see that if you
look at cb2 levels you know
essentially they were uh you know mostly
uh
if you had low medium or high it was
mostly that was the only virus that was
detected
occasionally we'd see it was about three
to four percent of the samples we see
the infection of an additional virus but
essentially
you can see for the most part it was
very rare so uh in
case you see pink here that means this
is an area where we would see
you know other viruses present and
generally uh not overlapping with star
cov2
so the next thing is we want to see or
do we see other microbial species indeed
we do
because it's a shock on rnac assay and
we can see here the common airway or
oral microbiome bacteria or those that
are shared
we can see for the most part they seem
pretty pretty common but in those
patients
with high viral titer we did see
evidence of a sort of viral
disruption of the microbiome as you can
see here particularly for some of these
species this is another
interesting feature that we're following
up with now on a lot of other larger
cohorts
so so that's the you know there's
viruses there's a bacteria we can see a
little trace of fungi and some of them
but now we want to look at the human
response so these are of course human
cells
that were infected we could start to
look at the differentially expressed
genes
or degs that could really classify
and give us a detail of what are the
genes that are most pronounced
and differentiated from as a consequence
of infection so here you can see the
upregulated genes in orange the down
regulated genes here in purple
and the degree of change on the x-axis
and also the statistical significance on
the y-axis so we can see
these genes in the upper right really
feature interferon stimulated genes
interferon regulation genes really
pushing the response in their interferon
pathways which has been replicated by
others multiple groups now
and you know if you do enrichment of
what are the biochemical pathways that
are enriched based on these genes
you can see a lot of them are familiar
pathways like uh antivirus bonds
interfering alpha
and if you're on gamma response to virus
but some of the surprising ones we're
really looking at heme and olfaction
really you can see olfactory
signaling pathways here you can see iron
binding hemoglobin complex
so things that link have linked us now
to some of the humanological
reality phenotypes from this infection
and this disease that are really
surprising is that some of you can call
it really not just a
respiratory disease but also a cardiac
disease and the damage from this we
don't even really understand in mono for
probably for years
if there's any long-term effects but um
but you can see here some of the
disruption these pathways evident in the
gene expression data
so in particular thinking about those
cytokines and interference signaling if
you look at just plot
again up regulated in orange down
regulator and purple the cytokines are
inflammatory or
interleukin receptor interleukin genes
you can see a lot of differential
expression particularly here
in high viral tighter and also in some
of the other influenza infections
and we're excited about making some of
these heat maps so we made actually a
nice web interface where
you can just go to
covergenese.wild.corner laddu and
actually use this as a way to
play with and mine the data and put up
any one gene or multiple genes or
pathways
and made this is a nice website
interface for people to uh really
get as much as they can out of the data
as we've been using it's actually we
can't share a patient by patient data
yet because of irb limitations
uh we want to make it so these people
could query them on this way so this is
free and available for anyone to use
as online now they've already used this
in a companion paper
uh they looked at complement factors so
in particular do we see this disruption
and indeed we do and we just published
this uh last month as well as a sort of
detailed examination
of how much we see this you know
disrupting in other contexts
particularly immune complement and
coagulation functions
so so that was a you know another
feature and then the last part of the
paper that i'll highlight is we were
able to start to look at what do we see
for
you know angiotensin converting enzyme
or angiotensin receptor blockers or arbs
there's you know ace inhibitors that a
lot of people are taking which if you
think about we see high levels of h2
uh expressed especially in patients with
a high viral titer
and what's intriguing about this is is
that that does mean you know this is a
way where
this could implicate if you're taking
ace inhibitors this could
change uh your risk potentially from
that consequence of the infection
so we went into the clinical metal
medical data the emrs uh from colombia
as well as cornell within the new york
presbyterian network
and then made mine these data
accordingly and we can see here that
your risk of infection if you're taking
ace inhibitors or arbs is actually
higher
but what's good is that your risk of
mortality was about the same or even a
little bit lower and so we don't think
that
this is the driving factor there were
some early reports in the outbreak that
maybe no one should take their ace
inhibitor drugs anymore or arbs
because they might die because people
were seeing infection rates higher but
we've now
known at least over we've examined over
50 000 patient records
across two campuses and we can see here
that that doesn't seem to be the case
for mortality so you can see
if you look at hypertension with or
without ace inhibitors you know these
are about the same and it's really
if you don't have hypertension that's
better but in general what's driving a
lot of the mortality is hypertension
writ large
uh regardless of whether you're taking
uh ac inhibitors so this doesn't seem to
be as big of a driver
and this is actually to my knowledge so
the biggest clinical cohort that's
looked at this question so
a little bit of relief a bit at the end
in terms of what this means for what
drugs might be taking
okay so i want to get into sort of this
second kind of a third part of my talk
which is to think about
how what else can we learn about what
the virus is doing during the infection
so in particular
could we look at digital spatial
profiling using a geomic system
from nanostring um and so you know it's
basically multiplex detection with full
uv photo cleavable barcode so basically
basically you
have oligo labeled antibodies and you
have a photo cleavable linker to that
oligo
and basically we can do a shine uv light
on here we can clip these out
and then sequence them and then
reconstruct essentially what was present
in a different tissue so this is
what's called spatial transcriptomics
which i think a lot of people in this
audience have either
seen or used but just a quick background
of what it is is basically uh there's a
spatial profile this is a
you know a flagrantly taken uh from some
of the nanostring slides of their
machine but you can see here
it's the best i think demonstration
images basically you stay in the slide
you can then image the regions of
interest or
areas of interest the rois or aois i'll
come back to that later
and then also you cleave the oligos you
can then pull them out you aspirate them
and then you put them into a plate and
you can sequence them for each one of
these regions of interest or areas of
interest
and then we hybridize and count based on
the tags that came through and then
reconstruct the image
of what was uh what was bound these uh
basically to these antibodies
so for example um what you can do is use
these basically it's a digital
micromirror device if anyone used the
old nimble gin arrays there's a similar
instrument that could do very small
micro mirrors to build microarrays you
can do the same
same technology to actually look at a
stain and then actually pull it out and
look at what's present
uh in a tumor or it could be for example
a coveted autopsy
so that's actually what we did here is
we actually took uh you know again the
dsp the library prep sequence on a
nexique 500 and then counts of analytes
uh to characterize what was present
this is done in uh tight collaboration
with rob schwartz and allen beaujec uh
two members of pathology faculty here at
cornell
and we collaborated with uh now string
to say okay well let's let's
think of the regions of interest from a
large airway of vascular zone
and alveoli zone and also look for
macrophages
in these regions of interest those those
that had high cd68 cells in particular
you know these were from some of the
very first autopsy patients that came
out that
unfortunately died at the hospital we
wanted to use the opportunity to learn
as much as we could about what it had
done to the body
so what we get from the aoi is after
some cleaning if they have too few
nuclei or
less than 50 genes they got pulled out
but the most where you can see you get
anywhere from usually
average to 500 to 1500 genes detected
per aoi and then also you can see
we saw more in general in the alveolar
sections that we examined but we look at
a lot more of those so i think those are
just some low counts here
now but you can see you know how many
did we look at for the alveoli large
airways and vascular regions
you can see over here on the right and
we looked at this in covid's patients
coveted autopsies
patients that had flu that died and with
no detected covid
uh normal lungs which come actually from
lung donors when they're doing a lung
transplant you can actually take a piece
of the lung and donate it and shave it
off and profile it
and then ards which is acute respiratory
distress syndrome to look at some of the
differences
so what we look we got from the the
comprehensive tumor atlas
assay which is basically the version of
geomets that focuses first on a lot of
the tumor-related genes
but it's about 1800 genes including
we've got some viral genes that we're
spiked in and i'll come back to these
little in a little bit
and they removed anything in 30 genes
that basically were below so the quality
cut off and then normalized them
based on negative probes for each assay
to get this sort of large heat map
of the samples and then also what we
could see for their clustering so that's
the first thing we want to do and say
well you can see some clustering but if
we put this into
an ordination plot you can see by
principal component analysis the normal
and flu samples clustered well but the
covid
and ards samples had much more
heterogeneity so we could actually see
you know just in the alveoli
some pretty clear differences uh between
them and so this is
you know one of the first things we saw
is uh cope it's a bit more heterogeneous
between the samples again it's only a
handful sample so we can't really
describe that much about it but it is in
preliminary results that show this
and we can also see you know different
gene expression rules if you look at flu
versus covid code versus not flu
covered versus normal there were
different responses some genes were
consistent
but in slightly different directions or
degrees and then also uh some of the
genes were
distinct but so but because there was so
much heterogeneity we didn't see
huge amounts of differential expressed
genes like we did for the np swabs but
there too we also had hundreds of
samples per group so it was a lot easier
to pick up
a signal nonetheless we could actually
see some differentiate express genes
and do enrichments to see except for one
patient that had a lot of noise we could
actually see
again cytokine signaling is a higher
overall factor in the alveolar samples
it really
seems to be driving some of the response
in the infection and kind of leading to
some of the challenges for the patients
and so you know this is
uh the gene center enrichment analysis
but then we wanted to validate this
with another method and get you know
better deconvolution kind of like i
referred to above
for the bulk rna-seq now we have a
chance actually to use what's called
qscd or quantitative single cell
deconvolution we can then
in a real really granular way tease out
what
what cell types are present uh what's
their abundance and
you know could we look at this for
unknown lungs like from the human cell
alice and compare them and so
uh this is indeed uh and what we did we
want to see what are the cell
proportions
uh that we think are you know present
for tissue and these are box plots the
cell proportions for each tissue type
you can see
the macrophages alveolar cells chelated
and blood vessel cells here
and you can see here for the different
samples you know we're seeing a lot of
expected
as you think large airway cells alveolar
cells cd68 positive cells because we
enrich for these
and so some of these things it makes
sense but then when we confirmed it we
want to see what do we see for each one
of the areas of interest as a vertical
plot
and then examine them in each of the
areas that we did genomic sounds there's
ldl our large airway vascular regions in
ce68
and these are again ards covered fluid
normal and here's what's really striking
is you can see this huge burst here of
macrophages particularly for this one
patient you can see each color here as a
patient
in other cases though we could see you
know really large burst as you know
effective you know like the
disruption of muscle cells and
fibroblasts uh that would show up here
and again macrophages popping up over
here so you know strange
really pushing uh the variation present
in these samples
uh distinguishing flu ards and covid but
really the immune infiltration we could
so we saw in kovid
was unlike anything else that we saw in
in most of the other tissues so really
a unique uh cellular distribution and
stress
on the coveted samples that we could see
elsewhere to put this in context what it
looks like when we do the spatial trench
comics this is actually
what it looks like is that here's kind
of the regions of interest and what gets
kind of cleaved off and then sequenced
and here's the different samples where
you can see if you do enrichments of
macrophages neutrophils fibroblasts
dendritic cells t cells
you can see here in some of the covalent
patients really striking enrichments
from macrophages for example
whereas ards we saw a lot more you can
see neutrophil enrichment
down here so really distinct cell
populations seem to be
involved in mediating the phenotype that
we're observing in these patients
in these different diseases so uh and
this just a kind of a zoom in here you
can kind of
look at where the proportions are and
you can look at the density as a
function
of the size but so since we're seeing
the human response in the human cell
type the next thing was to say well
can we validate this and also could we
start to pick up some of the important
receptors that are present so for
example tempus 2 or ace2
and also build in probes to look for the
virus and so what we did is this is the
rna scope
method which basically permeabilizes
tissues or cells you hybridize your to
your target rna
with these sort of double z probes that
are synthesized by rna scope
and you amplify the signal uh there's an
amplifier pre-amplifier molecule
you can then visualize that with a
general linear fluorescent platform
those plasmons
and they quantify single cell expression
so in particular
uh what we noticed is that actually
temperature 2 is detectable
but not really the other target so we
could see lots of that receptor
in a little bit of h2 but not as high
and not as much as the virus which i'll
come back to the end
it turns out these were samples uh we
first sent out the first batch we sent
were
ones that were later an infection where
the virus had cleared the lungs
and we're all getting some data
hopefully uh next week that has uh
samples at a much
higher load in the lungs the virus it
seems for most the patients we looked at
would move through the body and
eventually be cleared by the lungs and
you couldn't really detect it that much
after a while
okay so to give you some snapshots of
what we observed from the autopsy
samples is
again you can see uh tempur's two in
this case had high
uh you know little to none in the
alveoli you can see it had a lot in the
airway though
and this is against red here you can see
h2 we can pick up a little bit in some
cases but it's not as widely pronounced
but it is there and this also matches
some of the
uh early reports that h2 expression you
know it's higher but
um in most cases it wasn't you know
gangbusters higher but you can see it
there
but in this case tempers 2 was not as
common but if you look uh elsewhere in
this case we had high temperatures too
in the large airway and the alveoli you
can see here is popping up in different
locations over here
showing appears kind of pinkish red and
we can pick it up also in the second
sample
and this other covalent patient we saw
high temperatures too in both
both the large airway and the alveoli so
you can see here looking at these
different regions
you can see h2 kind of the ring around i
can see alveoli
and dna stain here and blue as a dappy
stain
and then h2 again popping up little bits
of tempers too
but high especially over here so in some
cases uh
you can see this really extraordinary
regional differentiation regional
heterogeneity
in the expression of the receptors and
also in the presence
of sort of you know their activity
around around the lungs and so this is
really
uh important to think about you know you
won't just have damage in one place
it'll be really heterogeneous uh when
the virus starts to get into cells from
what we've seen
and finally if you look at flu we did
see tempers tuned both large airway and
alveoli you can pick this up here again
through the pink here
uh pick it up just fine and that wasn't
as much of an issue that was
quite easy to pick up so um well
if i summarize what we have this part of
the talk before i get into the the third
part of the discussion and then kind of
closing is
you know we could see clustering and
differential gene expression results um
you know there's there are two
heterogeneous groups especially for
covered nerds
and normal and flu samples did seem to
be more consistent
we did not segregate yet whether it was
influenza a or b but we can see that we
just put them as flu and so
i would have enough samples to really
tease out subtypes of influenza quite
yet
uh we could see here that they're fairly
you know homogeneous
we saw the rna scope results uh okay so
that temperature is highly expressed in
large airways and sometimes there'll be
lessons but it's also extremely variable
in covet samples it could be everything
from highly dense to non-existent
depending on
where you looked in the lung finally the
qscd or
single cell deconvolution showed that we
could get you know
the cell types that are present in code
that are more variable and particularly
we could saw a huge burst of macrophages
in some of the patients
uh that really i think indicated some of
the immune stress and and tissue stress
that would be uh as a result of it
so uh looking ahead we want to think of
not just about
profiling and looking at the cells but
when i go in you know two different
directions i think the first one is
looking at why did some get sick and
some night at all why did some really
have to suffer the slings and arrows of
a really outrageous fortune
and in many cases die whereas others
could get infected could the infection
have
no problems whatsoever and how do we
better understand that so
what we've been contributing these data
to is the cova 19 host genetics
initiative so we can actually
give some of these data genome sequence
data expression data to people
to other groups to use certainly have no
monopoly on any of the good ideas in the
world
and also work with jean lauren casanova
and others at the coveted human genetic
effort
in this case to actually do more
profiling characterizing
of the code patients in total we're
doing this for a lot of the cornell
patients now is basically
doing whole genome single cell and ribo
rabbit depleted rna sequencing using uh
new england biolabs kits
uh in this case we're looking at the rna
to really characterize everything we can
most of things i just showed you so
viral genetic variation differential
expression looking at the ice forms now
epitope diversity
t-cell and b-cell receptor diversity
you're looking at hla types
polyadenylation sites skin loss of
microrna and then other rna viruses as
again as i've shown you
that we can pick up on the genome side
we're actually looking at genetic
variation
there as well looking at larger genetic
variants and also characterizing any
remaining
other species of metagenomic analysis
and finally looking at the health record
data
as i've also showed you from some of the
the mrns linked to the
emr's medical records so
that's uh what we've done in the papers
in review and we have other follow-on
work that's looking a lot more at
spatial
transcriptomic heterogeneity but i want
to
close on a couple directions which is to
think you know for the you know last uh
third or so the talk is well you know
could we be faster is there a way you
know
all this work i just showed you of
course is dependent upon
centralized large-scale laboratories and
big sequencers
to get you know these great in-depth
profiles of code patients
uh but you know we it doesn't help you
if you're waiting days for a diagnostic
test to be run or if you'd like to know
something faster so
about your your status and in fact my
daughter's going back to school this
week and
we're in ongoing discussions about you
know couldn't we just test every kid
when they walk in the door or could we
give kids to home
so there's actually been a lot of
development in this direction uh but
we want to think about lamp because this
is a very quick reaction which i'll
describe to you
and also it gives you a lot of
opportunity to look at even more
peculiar environments like in you know
the world writ large
so the reason speed is important is
because if you think about when you're
the most
infectious this is within the first week
you know days post symptoms
that's when you're carrying the most
viruses this is from the wolf foot wall
paper earlier this year
and so we know that speed is key you
can't have a two or three or four or
even
you know one day turnaround time is not
as good as same day
because you uh you're shedding virus the
whole time you're waiting for the
results so
we've known this for a while and we
started thinking about the speed is one
thing
we also started thinking about you know
the prevalence of it like where is the
virus in the world it's appearing all
over the place
is it in the environment and so we
leveraged a network called metasub or
the metagenomics of subways nearby
biomes group
which is starting they started in march
16th to sample public services and
hospitals
to look for the virus in particular we
have been tracking the virus
since april swabbing basically about 59
cities around the world
including 12 hospitals uh to
characterize you know what's there are
we seeing the virus is it still
potentially infectious
uh and i'll get back to that shortly but
the very first data we got from the new
york city subways didn't show any uh
cov2 fortunately let me go back this
year
but it did show influenza it did show a
few other known common viruses
uh rubella viruses we saw phages we saw
even
uh plant viruses and most of the other
rna was human or just not known so
a bit of good news in the early days we
didn't see it ramping across the subway
at least across those 50 samples
but then we started to see it in other
places like it showed up in cats at one
point so cats are now known carriers of
most kinds of coronaviruses
there is yet to have been as far as i
know a case of
cat to human transmission but there are
plenty of cases of human-to-cat
transmission
and so it does you know raise this
interesting question of well how many
else are out there and
you know could we uh learn more about
this we actually just launched a project
uh got irb approval for testing other
people's cats and comparing that to
their own symptoms so if you go to the
medisub website
and if you'd like a swab kit for testing
out your cat to see what's there
uh it's free to get it and we'll take a
look and give you a report on how many
funky coronaviruses are hanging around
your
cat's mouth but that's one weird place
to start to look at and the other thing
we started looking at was
you know on hospital services so in
particular we uh worked with northwell
hospital
and lance becker is to say well if we
started doing rt pcr
in the hot zone versus warm or cold zone
what do we see and so these areas hot
sun means
in the room of a patient there's
actually a coveted positive patient in
that room
warm zone are the areas nearby on that
floor it could be the nurse's station
areas that are effectively it could be
you know they've been clean but they
still could be contaminated
and the cold's under places where you'd
expect no virus presence on a different
floor
or very far away and also have been
recently decontaminated
so what we could observe actually if you
look at this is a schematic is a number
of viral copies per square centimeter
based on our tpcr metrics
was you know we were picking things up
in the hot zone we could see it on the
the bed railing sort of the equipment
the curtain the floor
if you look at the other place like a
work station we could pick it up in the
hot zone we can see it there in the
bathroom
you can see in the bathroom was on the
the handle for the toilet as well as on
the ceiling
and what that means is that actually the
virus is being aerosolized and shot
through the air
like kind of like a nuclear bomb it's
kind of like instead of fecal fallout uh
you know it's like fieldfollow instead
of nuclear fallout you have fecal
fallout basically
uh as the particles are hitting the
flying through the air and hitting the
ceiling so
uh that answers the age-old debate of
should you put the lid down or should
men do it or
should women do it everyone should just
do it so please do uh if you're in a
place
uh that has a lid whereas the cold zone
we didn't see it that much
around the surface but we could see it
sometimes on the floor uh and in the
cold zone and sometimes even there on
the ceiling so
uh you know these things can and do show
up in different places
in hospital but getting back to the
earlier thought of okay we did a shot
that's our tpcr but what if we did
shotgun rna sequencing and then use the
same
pipeline and math reads then call
variants uh we can you know could we
actually try and improve where they came
from using some of the same phylogenetic
and geospatial
next strain databases indeed we could
it's a leading question so you can guess
the answer
here we can see this is the coverage for
each one of the genomes that we picked
up and you can see sometimes you can
even get
construction of the entire viral genome
just from what's on the walls of the
hospital by itself so in other cases you
just get little fragments of the genome
you can see little spikes
uh what we could pick up around the
hospital and so this tells us that you
know there is a way to you know track
really the likely origin of a virus just
by sequencing it including sequencing
hospital services obviously patients and
more recently we started to work on cats
and so it was really
there's still quite a bit to uh to learn
uh
just from what's in our environments and
uh and what's cool those with these kind
of databases we can tell
what we're doing right now is comparing
the travel history and sort of patient
background
with the inferred origin of the viruses
and then getting a little bit of uh we
have an irb of looking at
you know how close can we get from their
questionnaire and also the viral genetic
sequence information
which is ongoing study so that's in the
sequencing in the environments but then
the other place we were not want to
think about speed
uh it you know is is you know l is also
in hospital so you think about here like
again we took samples got them from the
hospital sequence them very interesting
kind of built but
wouldn't it be great if we could just
tell if a room was contaminated within
20 or 30 minutes
and that brings us back to lamp is the
loop needed isothermal implication
this is a chemistry that was uh
commercialized by newing and biolabs and
also put into multiple formats
and we've been working with them closely
really since uh february on this to get
things up and running
and this basically instead of having two
primers for a target so it's kind of a
cousin of pcr if you're not familiar
with this
but instead of having two primers to
target one locus you actually have six
primers that end up help creating a loop
that gives us a template for rapid
amplification hence the loop part of
lamp
and it's isothermal because it runs at
the same temperature in this case
you take rna you can convert it to cdna
with a warm start reverse transcriptase
and there's a strand is placing dna
polymerase bst
that then quickly makes these big loops
and so what's cool about it is actually
there were some primers
uh we got from nathan tanner that came
out early on in february and said okay
let's see
if these work on the genome took them on
some samples first was the
titrated twist synthetic rnas from 0 1
10 100 onward up to a million copies
and log 10 dilutions and you can see the
reaction starts pink elizabeth phenol
red
but after a little while it actually
starts to get a color metric shift you
can see really quickly if the virus is
there and then after about 30 or 40
minutes you can see you know you've got
an lod that's between
maybe 10 or 100 copies of what you can
pick up for the virus
and so we're excited about this control
but then we tried it actually on
additional controls it worked we tried
it on a
clinical sample that was known clinical
positive and then ran lamp and that also
worked fine you can see it turns this
beautiful brilliant yellow and we can
say okay it seems like this is really
working
the next thing we want to do is say well
what how does this look if we compare it
to
rna seeker or qpcr and so we did this
across about 211 samples we could see
here
this is the ct threshold on the x-axis
so a higher being lower copy of iris as
you probably know
and then the percentage number of reads
on the y-axis though is up here as
higher as more amounts of the virus
total number of reads
uh detected from the sample and you can
see the lamp perimeter reader is how
much of the
of the product was made at a fixed
interval of 30 minutes you can see the
correlation you know it's a negative
correlation to ct values expect
was overall uh decently correlated so we
can actually
use this as a uh it's definitely uh
quality quality metric you can say well
as a yes or no is the virus present
but you can to some degree use it as a
quantification of the amount of virus
present
so we did this and compared to known
positives and non-negatives we could see
here
we got about 99 specificity and up to 94
sensitivity depending on where we put
our thresholds for for the really high
viral abundant samples it was perfect
but
as you start to get to ct values of 28
30 33 35
in that range uh you'll start to see it
drop down to sensitivity
down more like 80 so there's there is
like a lot of essays at the lower limits
you'll start to see some something
basically some law drop out but this was
in the early days we only had one primer
in the reaction
uh we'd since uh again worked with new
england biolabs and a lot of other
collaborators in a working group called
glamp
to say what if we get you know two
primers in the same tube and look at the
reaction so for the
nucleocapsid and the envelope gene and
we got it down to really reliably at 25
copies per tube or even 10
in some cases that we could pick up uh
you know from this reaction so
that was you know in the early days back
in february march april
uh by when we started working with
really anybody we possibly could we
wanted to
look at this and start to ramp it up and
we got uh it started working with color
back in
the end of march to say well here's the
protocol here's the method sent
everything over
they got it working well really quickly
and we got that they got the first fda
approval for lamp
for this color metric lamp uh
out in san francisco it's now being used
to test about 10 to 12 000 people in san
francisco every day
so this is one of our first success
stories with lamp and getting it out
from
really something kind of working at the
bench it seemed exciting out into a
large-scale clio lab for testing
uh we've also been testing it in the
emergency room in our own lab here at
well kernel medicine
and you know the exciting thing is you
know this you know that worked and that
was it was cool because we test a lot of
people really quickly
uh deploy it you know people are getting
rapid turnaround time and still are to
this day in san francisco so that's
great
but it's still you know we still had
this quest to say could it be faster you
know and here
we've done this before something kind of
like this where we did pop-up labs once
at the abr meeting
a couple years ago this is if you
remember this is way back in the day
when people used to go to meetings see
each other and shake hands and
go out and have after seminar beers and
brainstorm
we'll get back to that that time someday
but any case
uh these ideas pop up we've done this
before at this meeting we swabbed
people's phones when they came in
and then we extracted sequence prep and
then reported back the result at the
same meeting
and there we just did it about 48 hours
later but we know it's possible that
optimizes to make it faster so
we started thinking more and more about
doing pop-up labs and empowering people
in different cities to actually do some
of their own testing so one of them in
particular is
racine wisconsin my brother is the mayor
there actually and he
said you know called me up and said
chris well you know i see you're posting
stuff on twitter and facebook about
the stuff there's new testing it looks
great but can you come help us all we're
doing right here for testing
is taking people's temperatures so can
you please come help so we set up this
same lab
uh in racine and got this set up over
the summer so it drove across country
brought a bunch of lab equipment got it
set up
and got it working quite well and this
regard
you know made it so we didn't just get
the test up but we also trained
firefighters how to do pipetting and
testing so the idea was not just to set
up another pop-up lab which has been
done before and we've done that before
but to really uh enable a kind of a
democratization of the access to the
technology to get the testing working so
in this regard you know can we have it
some people anyone could do a
firefighter a police
policeman or woman could be a city
official anyone can actually learn a
little bit of pipetting
and some labeling uh and then run the
test indeed we showed those possible
i got that up and running and there's
actually a bit of coverage of this also
in wired it was
it was literally in a former boxing gym
there were still signs of about
boxing routines and how to take your
shower so it was really
it looked a little bit like a meth lab
to be frank with you and it felt some
days like a meth lab but
it was enough to get some basic
equipment set up and get things running
and then
have a little molecular body lab set up
in wisconsin so
we are not the only ones what's exciting
about this is
this idea and and this protocol has
really led to a large working group so
in particular
uh we started something um you know with
uh originally starting
with collaboration england bio labs
testing for america
also help from with uh color is to say
can we have a pre-competitive space for
people who are working on lamb for assay
optimization deployment automation
and share everything with each other
indeed that's what we've been doing uh
once a week it's open anyone 12 o'clock
on thursdays
it's really people present people
brainstorm sometimes people
you know commiserate about what's
working what's not working and really
try to learn from each other as fast as
possible
so that we can iterate quickly on design
and really address the pandemic so
everything that works or doesn't work
are are both important for a lot of what
we're doing here
and so we've been rolling it out there
in racine we've also now been doing it
at cornell i'll say newark medical
college
has been launched since the end of may
medical college wisconsin is also
ongoing and mass general
is pending but they've been doing some
testing a little bit there and this has
gone to other clinical sites we've been
doing environmental sites including
uh for jet propulsion laboratories when
they're taking a break from building
uh spacecraft they want to get tested
north wales ongoing also
uh university of vermont has been
testing uh all their uh science
buildings for the past couple months
that's led by scott thai and we're in
the process of launching these sites now
for fall and for different schools
uh for helping them as well so in the uh
last uh last few minutes last bit of the
talk i want to go through like you know
again this is
you know still you still here you need
you know equipment you need to buy
pipettes you need to get things in place
we want to open this up and make it even
easier for people basically as you know
can we make it uh
even easier yet so in particular we met
with david erickson who's a faculty also
at cornell and also eagle fisherman
and he had already created a device back
in 2017 and 18
i called the tiny which is the tiny
isothermal and nucleic
amplification system tiny and you can
see here is a collaboration between ucsf
and cornell and the engineering
department
and infectious disease institute but in
particular it's to make a small box that
includes
everything you need to run lamp so this
is basically the heating element as well
as a
ability to detect the fluorescent change
that could work either with fluorescent
or color metric change
it runs on power but it also can run on
electricity earlier it can run the flame
or sunlight you can see here so
it's very you know low footprint easy to
use very cheap
uh and it's already published and you
know this was something that works
basically you can get pcr tubes into a
small matrix
uh there's basically photodiodes at the
bottom that can detect any changes uh
really in you know the absorbance of
this spectrum from
lower 500s up to almost 700 nanometers
of their wavelength so it covers
you know a lot of the known fluorophores
that you might look at for different
probes
and you can you know pick it up quite
readily and it's just a little heat
insulation and absorption plate and it
looks like that so it's really easy to
run
it runs on a small arduino chip and you
can actually run your own version of
lamp and so
this is what we want to try and uh build
with david and we got the protocol
up and running from some of the first
results back in may and june we can see
here if you have nothing in your sample
it stays flat but if you have a positive
control in this case we used here is a
known clinical positive we can see as
the amplification goes up you see the
absorbance change you can see the blue
sample come up and so
this is what the raw data looks like in
this case it was positive within 10
minutes
but we also didn't want you know
converting this now so it's a more
cleaned up output but basically it's
pretty easy to see when it was positive
versus just flat meaning there's nothing
there
uh or it's a negative uh you know
non-amplified virus like an influenza
for example
so this this tiny box and this kind of
uh tiny and lamp
combo platform it's something we've now
got up and running in the emergency room
so we call this the the
lamp cart where you take the cam the
cart around and you can actually uh run
lamp but then we've now converted it to
you can see here on the right
uh just a cart that you can run on this
box and just plug it in and you've got
everything you need so basically
it's almost like a little cart you can
wheel around and test people as you need
and this is what we have for an irb
setup
to collect saliva from patients as they
walk through the emergency room
and so there's a led by dan butler and
chris masara from lab we really
deserve a lot of credit who were quite
literally on the front lines
uh every day collecting samples working
with patients
uh processing um disgustingly large
amounts of saliva
as well as other bodily fluids and
samples that came from many places so um
so that's so we think in the future um
actually one deal we just signed is
working a bit with foxconn to
manufacture these devices at scale so
this is something we want the the
technologies all open source and the
parameters the metrics
and we're working with a large-scale
manufacturer to make it so anyone can
have these
you know basically is lab equipment but
also even home testing equipment this is
something if you want to just run some
testing
on your own or a school or a city hall
uh working to make this a reality and i
think we'll have a lot of them available
very soon so in closing i want to thank
everyone in the lab we make this
possible they're
really inspiring and awesome group and
uh phenomenal to work with
this is um you can see again back in the
days when we still hang out in person
you can see we go to a place called
pickaxe which is where you
throw uh axes and drink beer which
sounds like an awful idea but it's
actually a lot of fun so i highly
recommend it whenever
places open up and again then you can go
hang out and you can see it's the lab
there and thank of course funding
uh from citadel who donated in world
quant a lot of philanthropy pershing
that three in the upper right uh
foundation wise helped a lot
plus the nih uh ctsc and also the gates
foundation
and thanks of course to not only
everyone in my lab and many
collaborating labs who've helped out
uh over the years and still to this day
and thank you very much
for your time
i don't have to take any questions
and thank you dr mason for that
informative presentation
we will now start the live q a portion
of the webinar
if you have any questions you want to
ask please do so now
just click on that ask a question box
located on the far
left of your screen so let's get started
we've got some great questions already
coming in we have a fantastic audience
today
for this conference dr amazing
can you describe the host and viral
responses
from the infection for sars kovi cov2
yes i think broadly the what we've seen
enriched is that the interferon response
is most pronounced the isgs or
interference stimulated genes
almost all of them are really activated
as you'd expect for a
kind of a coronavirus or other infection
flavor viruses will see similar things
and so
uh this is an expected response but what
was kind of unexpected
is i think the degree of the immune cell
infiltration that's leading to
even more inflammation than one most
notable that people probably seen is
il-6
which really spiked from infection um
ironically the only place we saw
something quite so high
was work we done with nasa astronauts
upon landing
we saw also back to earth that there was
a really huge enrichment of ielts sticks
uh for scott kelly when he got back to
earth after being in space for a year so
we can see
uh strange strange things that don't
normally show up but are really spiking
up high
in the coveted patients absolutely
dr mason there seems to be a big
controversy about whether
children should be going back to school
versus online learning with what you
know about the virus
what is your professional opinion about
us
uh this is a great well i can tell you
also personally
um you know it's a struggle because on
the one hand
we know there are clear damage you know
there's a clear damage to social
development for children if they don't
engage with other children and have
normal
pedagogical you know essentially
interface and development
uh as school children but you don't want
them to die so
you know they're pretty too hard choices
but they i don't want them to die
is the default best choice and right now
you know i think
the answer is it's going to be depend
very much on where you are and so if
positivity rate
is low enough your risk is by definition
low
and for example in new york city they've
said if the positivity rate pops up
above three percent
at any point they're gonna reinitiate
the shutdown and so
uh three percent you can argue and
haggle over that number but basically
it's got to be a number
anywhere between one to five percent is
generally what has been published
is that at some point starts to get too
risky to start to put people together
because um if you're in
rooms of you know even 10 or 15 kids if
it's around five percent positivity
uh you're starting to get close to the
odds that one of them would have it if
they do that's just too high of a risk
so
right now you know what we're gonna be
doing is playing really week by week or
day by day and so right now we're
sending
our daughter back to school next week in
person uh but about 40 percent of
parents in new york city
which largest school district in the
country have said no we're just going to
stay remote
you know regardless of what that does to
your you know parental sanity your home
life
and they just decided it's too dangerous
so i'm i'm following the data and right
now the positivity rate's extremely low
in new york state's about point
three percent was the last number i saw
so the odds are very low that
if you need one in a school of several
hundred people would have it uh so that
we're gonna and if it starts to go up
though
we'll probably pull her back out um
because it's very easy
we're fortunate enough that we have uh
you know enough room in the house and
and
and support from friends and family uh
that i think we can do it uh remotely
i think that's been a common message
throughout the conference follow
the data listen to the science
um why do the host and viral responses
vary between the coronaviruses
uh so some of it is just that what uh
there's two two reasons one is or at
least two reasons there's probably many
but at least two of the driving ones are
that the virus itself
you know is shaped differently so uh the
spike protein is one we've all heard a
lot about
but the other proteins and components of
the virus the way it enters the cells is
different the shape of the nucleocapsid
uh the full varion capsule is different
in different coronal viruses so
that slight differentiation leads to
greater or less mobility and speed
as how it goes through cells and the
second really big reason
is the tropism of the virus changes in
two ways one is
where does the virus go in your body
which is the tropism in general what's
getting infected at what speed how long
does it persist
as i was saying earlier the lungs seem
to get infected early and then clear the
infection
even in cases where you know patients
ended up dying because we had the
autopsy
you know the virus was already gone from
the lungs but it had caused so much
damage and so much immune infiltration
that's what i ended up killing the
patients um and so you know it's a
tropism where the virus goes and then
what the virus what the virus does after
it's gone so what the tropism of
it's kind of like the shadow tropism of
how how many cells came in afterward
to disrupt what was present for the
normal biology
thank you so much and again i want to
thank our audience members for these
great questions
we have time for one more question dr
mason clearly the federal government has
made some mistakes
we can't turn back time but if you were
the president
right now why what would you do in
regards to mandates and protocols
to reduce the illnesses and deaths
moving forward
uh yeah great it is um it's always been
true you can't turn back the clock so
with the where we are today is what we
have to act on but if i
were president tomorrow and i ran as a
third party and i beat biden and trump
let's say um you know the simple thing
is what the director of cdc said
yesterday is that really wearing a mask
is the simplest and one of the most
powerful ways to reduce infection we
know that so
i would uh you know encourage everyone
to wear a mask or even
in cities where they're seeing outbreaks
it should be mandated um
and so to any of those people who think
it's an affront
to liberty to cover your face with
something i think the greater affront to
liberty is if you uh purposely infect
someone and kill them
and there's been plenty of criminal
cases for people with hiv who infected
others
who went to jail if they knowingly
infect others uh but in this case most
people
who are infecting others don't know that
they're infecting others right so i
think
uh the greater infringement of liberty
is if you kill someone
even if you don't mean to and so a
simple way to avoid that is just to wear
a mask so i would probably even go in
that direction
and make it it's a simple thing that you
can be stylistic about it you know it
can make it kind of clever why not
also do that and then also just have
testing uh be more
rapid scale and widespread there there's
still to this day is no federal response
really effectively
except for funding ideas in many
directions to try and come up with new
testing modalities and vaccine research
which is wonderful but there's no
coordinated federal response on the
testing side per se they've really left
each state to its own devices which has
led to a
really an awful patchwork response uh
that certainly did not contribute to
um you know the health and safety of the
nation so uh or the world for that
matter so um
so that's what i would get but um i
think we'll get out of it eventually
there's enough testing in vaccines in
the works i think
someday we'll get back to some semblance
of normality just going to take a while
absolutely dr mason thank you again for
today would you like to provide any
closing remarks for our audience before
we go
um you know keep the faith um try and
uh keep a good schedule and uh we'll
you know well i think eventually we'll
get uh we'll be at a conference together
again
uh having some of the same conversations
and brainstorming sessions
dr chris mason thank you again for your
time today and for your important
research and before we go i want to
thank our audience members for joining
us today
and for their interesting questions i'd
also like to thank
lab roots for hosting today's conference
questions we did not have time for today
and those submitted during the on-demand
period will be
addressed by our speaker via the contact
information you provided at the time of
registration
and this webcast can be viewed on demand
for six months
up till march 2021. labradoods will
alert you via email when it's available
for replay
we encourage you to share that email
with your colleagues who may have missed
this live event until next time be safe
and stay healthy
take care bye thank you